バナー
まつがいで1800を買ったんですけど
[音楽]
ちょっと多いかなちょっと大方ちょうど食べごろなんですよもしガラスポットが最高に
美味しい
食べる旬の月まできちゃってるんですけどそこは俺ですよねここは俺様ですこれをこれ
だけでも100本全然超えてるんですよ
どうすればいいですかいやーこれがですね結構深刻な悩みで
バーンって生物なんで何かその友達とか後輩とか族とかなんか擦り合いの人に渡すのは
全然いいんですけど知らない人に渡しても時代は体調崩しちゃったり体調崩しちゃった
ような変な食中毒とかアフィ飲む人が入ってるなんかとっくに入っちゃったりしたら僕
が殺したことになるんですよ
セファ
ピュアっぽさせるに僕の周りの人で配れなかったんですよ
というわけでバナナは
でまぁ生バーナーを捨てません誰にも渡せないん
人間以外に食べさせればいいというわけで実はですねあの動物園の人に連絡を取りまし
てそちらの道分前にはだが好きな方いませんかと連絡したところ
カミさんが食べてくれるみたいでいつかぐらい経てど全員様みたいなことを園長さんに
言われたので今から動物園の人にヴァンダーの1800本と時に行ってきます
では行こう
me
ええええええ
じゃない重すぎん絶対ねーじゃん
ああ
ガーン
ああああああ
のえっ
怒ってる
はいという間にもその2ゴミが終わったので早速溝前の院長のところに向かおうと思い
ますでは
スッと思うよん
[音楽]
すごい反響いつもいつも
エフェスカーッとすごいねほんとにほんとにすぐ開いて行きで以前の延長だねぇ
さあ
bouvet だったらやっぱ30キロ走も運よく
と思いますよ
8詐欺この子ヘビや食べない花のじゃないとしてるけどさぁそれ故
押し寄せバッハ恋来いろいろいなかったので本当ですか
んですよ同社をしたで食べさせてみている
はいまあまあ
2引っ張り合ってる売れないの
すごい屋さん
そりゃじゃないですか今後食べるよ店
あーた別後は食べて貼って5位すごい俺の場合ならそれ
落ちたバカなバーガー好物あそうなんだろう
俺の花花よさって今近づけたら目5分
花よ
を
どうぞ
[音楽]
を
ちょっと近づけて口の3あああうん
狭いと思うん
ん
解説よねっと言わなそうそういやそんなんだったら大丈夫だと自分でっくぢば裏四
パー
アメちゃんあなただけ食べるのにということん
おおーー
oo
パーサーは誰か助けてくれるとチョコ
飛びかかり b されちゃうっ
ですねちょっと持っています愛するお願いいたします
整備のございます
ああああああああああああ
もうちょっと萌えねーのっ
全4色ありがとうございますさあ
これで全部です全部本当にいいんですよこんな業だよね
ご視聴ありがとうございますねありがとうございます等があります
指がある第3にしてやってみようじゃないぞ像だけじゃないって
というわけでえっと僕のバーガーを食べているウミガメは何というすごいね僕の
バーナーを食べてるぞと目は何という伊豆
動物にいるので皆さん見に来てみてくださいこれはバナナ
勝利できなかったら塩蔵せたのでだぞまた作り手の遊びに来ない
またチャールダーシュじゃん
南に行くぞぞー画像がですっ
car
me
えっあっはぁ